Shall we go to Dubai or to Riyadh? That is a crucial question occupying the minds of CEOs and other boards of directors,
in some of the world's largest companies today, that want to have regional headquarters in the Middle East and North Africa
in order to oversee and manage their business and operations here in the region.
Until recently, this question was not being asked.
Simply because any international company that was thinking of implementing a regional headquarter here in the region
would undoubtedly choose Dubai.
For two reasons.. The first is that Dubai, as one of the most successful global cities,
provides almost all the advantages and facilities that any international company might dream of or need
in order to launch its operations all over the countries of the region through it.
For example, we will find international companies established in countries such as Egypt, Saudi Arabia, Tunisia, Algeria
and others, but they are managed from the Dubai International Financial Center
or Dubai Internet City through the regional headquarters of those companies there.
The second reason is that in reality, for many years, there was no real and strong competitor in the region for Dubai
that is keen to offer the same advantages that the Emirati city offers
to multinational companies interested in being present in the region.
In Europe, there are Zurich, Frankfurt, London, Paris, Amsterdam and Geneva all vying for regional corporate headquarters.
In Asia there are Hong Kong, Singapore, Tokyo, Shanghai, Beijing, Shenzhen and Seoul.
In North America there are New York, San Francisco, Los Angeles, Boston, Washington, Chicago and Toronto.
Here in the region, there is virtually no other than Dubai.
I know that there are international companies with regional headquarters in Cairo, Riyadh,
Abu Dhabi, Manama and Casablanca, but all these cities combined
do not have half the number of regional headquarters located in Dubai.
This is the current situation, but it seems that Dubai will not remain the only player.
This is simply because Saudi Arabia for the first time started to put this in mind.
During the last two years, the Kingdom's keenness to make Riyadh
the economic capital and the most important financial center in the region was clearly evident.
This is the title that Dubai currently enjoys.
The bottom line is that the Saudi efforts in this direction are so serious that we are now watching mega international companies
moving their regional headquarters from Dubai to Riyadh, as we will explain later.
Other companies that are still new to the region are going directly to Riyadh, not to Dubai.
In short, there is an economic boom currently taking place in the heart of Riyadh for the first time.
This situation really makes us ask some serious questions, including:
Why are companies confused in choosing between Dubai and Riyadh?
What might Riyadh offer to make international companies
that want to establish headquarters in the region choose them instead of Dubai?
Is there a precise Saudi plan to achieve this?
Can we consider Riyadh's efforts as direct competition with Dubai? Will Dubai stand idly by?
Are we in the midst of a fierce competition between the two cities,
as is the fierce competition between Singapore and Hong Kong?
The most important question is, why this competition over this issue in the first place?
What is the gain for any country if it attracts a large number of regional headquarters of international companies to its lands?
This is a sampling of the significant questions we'll be discussing in today's episode.
But before that, I want to remind you that half of those who are watching us until today are still not subscribed to the channel.
I am asking those who are not yet subscribed to the channel to do so.
Your subscription is one of the substantial reasons that galvanize us to present the Economic Informant
with the same quality, and go further in developing it.
PLEASE, activate the notification button to see each new episode, God willing...
I am Ashraf Ibrahim, and this is the Economic Informant
This episode is sponsored by Wuilt, the first Arab platform through which you can create your own website or online store
for your business in just 5 minutes. It's easy, fast, and its cost is low.
Whether you are selling a product online [you are a lawyer, a doctor or even a designer] you can easily make your website.
As you know, most things are done online now. Almost all people have a smartphone.
The advantage in working on your website is that instead of reaching 50 or 100 customers in the vicinity of your office
or shop, you can now reach thousands of customers on the Internet, which will increase your sales, God willing.
Try logging in the Wuilt platform and making your site or store yourself without having any experience in programming
or design at all. It is pretty much easy. You will find a link to the site in the video description
below and in the Facebook comments.
In the early eighties, East Asian countries such as China and Japan, and Asian tigers such as South Korea, Taiwan, Hong Kong
and Singapore, were able to achieve giant economic successes.
The most notable feature of these successes is that they were not based on neither the socialist model,
nor the traditional Western capitalist model based on the free market without state intervention.
Because, unlike the socialist model, those Asian countries did not fully control the economy,
on the contrary, they gave the private sector large free space. On the other hand, unlike the free capitalist model,
these governments did not let the economy or development paths run completely free.
That is, they did not absolutely let the rules of the free market lead the country.
Well, what were they doing?
The approach taken by these countries can be considered a combination between socialist and capitalist
[half socialist, half capitalist] rules. Briefly, the governments of those countries had certain development agendas.
It wanted to achieve goals in certain development sectors. To do so,
it intervened in the economy by guiding the private sector and helping it achieve that agenda.
For example, in the case of the giant electronic chip industry in Taiwan, which is considered the most advanced in the world.
The one that drew up the plan in the eighties, saved resources and decided to take the country towards this path,
is the Taiwanese government itself. Yet, the one that implemented the plan at the time
and that owns the same industry today is the private sector.
Consequently, terms such as the “capitalist developmental state” -
the “state-sponsored capitalism” -
and the “guided capitalism” popped up since then.
In fact, this is the closest pattern to the path that the UAE city of Dubai has followed in its development plan.
You can say that all of Dubai's successes are the result of initiatives launched by the government in the city,
with the participation of the private sector itself in their implementation and success later.
We can say that those responsible for planning for Dubai had their eyes on Singapore all along.
That's why Singapore and Dubai are very similar in so many ways.
In this context, Dubai decided to invest its revenues from oil, which are few compared to the revenues of Abu Dhabi,
by the way, in developing economic activities that could generate great income for it in the future
in order to build a developed and sustainable economy, and the intention was to develop a service economy.
Here the regime in Dubai made an amazing shift in economic development that is rarely repeated..
The natural path of development that most developed countries followed was through the transition from agriculture
to non-agricultural activities, or from industry to a service economy.
But in Dubai, the shift has been from an economy based on trade and pearl fishing,
to an economy based on services directly, like Singapore,
whose service sector employs more than 84% of its workforce, and is responsible for more than 70% of GDP.
But, in order to create a developed service economy in a city like Dubai, in the way it was in the seventies,
a great change needed to be done. Government officials in Dubai put a lot of money into infrastructure projects:
roads, ports, airports, and the development and improvement of public services such as electricity, water,
and telecommunications. But all this, despite its importance, is not enough to make the city the focus of attention for
international companies that might be interested in being present in the Middle East.
That is why Dubai has made laws, institutional frameworks, legislation and regulatory rules
that govern the rules of work in the city and make things easier for companies and for any visitor to the city above all.
At the same time, it provided tax and customs privileges for companies, and not only that.
The government also launched important strategic projects such as Dubai Internet City, Dubai Media City,
Dubai International Financial Center, and Dubai World Trade Center, other than free trade zones and tourism projects.
All of this was eventually translated into the fact that today's Dubai has become one of the most important cities in the world.
The most important and largest financial center in the Middle East and North Africa.
The place where most of the regional headquarters of international companies
in the region and even the media reside.
This is natural, given that Dubai provides companies and individuals
with almost all the facilities and services that they can obtain in large global cities such as New York and London.
What is not normal is that our region, for a long time, has had no other city like Dubai.
There is no strong competitor to the city, an important note,
which is that the closest competitor to Dubai as a financial center is its peer Abu Dhabi, i.e the Emirates as well.
The absence of competition has had a direct result of the concentration of most of the regional headquarters
of international companies in Dubai, regardless of the markets they target.
I.e, One can find a company whose main market is the Egyptian market, yet its regional headquarters are in Dubai, not Cairo.
A TV channel targeting the Saudi audience, based in Dubai, not Riyadh.
An institution targeting the Algerian market based in Dubai, not Algeria, and so on..
In fact, this is a skill on the part of the Emiratis who were able to provide the environment and conditions
that convinced international and even Arab companies to take Dubai as a starting point for their operations and activities
in the region, regardless of the country or countries targeted by these economic activities.
The whole region has reconciled with this situation ever since, but in the last two years it has been pretty clear
that officials in Saudi Arabia have a different plan whose goal, in short,
is to make the capital, Riyadh, the most important city in the region financially, economically and commercially.
It is the title that Dubai currently enjoys, as we said in the first episode.
Let us look at the global ranking of Arab capitals in the list of the largest financial centers in the world.
We will find Dubai first in the Arab world and 17th in the world.
Then Abu Dhabi ranked 32, then Casablanca ranked 54th,
then Doha ranked 57, then Bahrain ranked 81, then Riyadh ranked 98,
and finally, Kuwait which is ranked 108th in the list of the most important financial centers in the world.
Riyadh does not like its arrangement. It wants to be number one,
and this is an ambitious project based on the fact that the capital of the country
has the richest and largest economy in the region.
Perhaps the most significant desire of the Saudis is that
they want to achieve their goal much faster than the time needed by Dubai to reach its current position.
In order to achieve this, the Saudis decided to use two different methods in parallel and at the same time
within the principle of "carrot-and-stick", so to speak.
The first method, "the stick", is the difficult method in which the financial and economic weight of the Saudi state is exploited.
The second method, "the carrot", is the soft one through which all the privileges and facilities that international companies
meight need to open their regional headquarters in Riyadh are provided [which they are already enjoying in Dubai].
Ok, one may wonder how this happens on the ground?
Well, that is how…
In February 2021, Saudi Finance Minister Mohammed Abdullah Al-Jadaan
made a surprising and interesting statement to Reuters. He said that the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia,
which is the largest economy in the region and the largest exporter of oil all over the world,
will completely stop awarding any government contracts to international companies
that have a regional headquarters in the region outside Riyadh, and this will be implemented starting from 2024.
The words of the Saudi officials to international companies were simply and briefly as follows:
You want to obtain contracts for mega projects whose value reaches billions of dollars and sometimes tens of billions?
You have to establish your regional headquarters in Riyadh, not in any other city in the region.
You are free: take it or leave it. But starting from January 1, 2024, and this is still by the lips of the Saudi officials,
no company will get even a single contract from the government.
Of course, you can work with the Saudi private sector freely, as you know.
But acquiring government contracts without your headquarters inside Riyadh! It won't happen.
The Saudi minister, explaining the reasons for this sudden decision, told Reuters:
We cannot be the owners of the largest economy in the region, and at the same time, Saudi Arabia's share of
the regional headquarters of international companies located in the region is only 5%.
Other than that, we want to attract more international companies to invest in Saudi Arabia.
On the one hand we provide job opportunities for Saudis.
On the other hand, we diversify our economy and make it less dependent on oil.
The most prominent feature of the Saudi decision announced by Al-Jadaan was not being a bold decision only,
but in fact it is a big bet on the part of the Saudis using their financial and strategic influence.
A bet from their side on the great economic importance of their country for international companies,
which are supposed to be interested in preserving their great interests and business with the Kingdom’s government,
and for this you will see that it is in their interest that their regional headquarters be located in Riyadh.
Since it is a bet like any other bet in the world, the Saudis may win or lose.
There is about a year left until the end of the government's deadline for international companies,
but from the time the decision was announced until now, it seems, and God knows best, that it is a winning bet.
How is that?
Attention please…
In October of the same year, Al-Jadaan’s statement, 2021, and during the “Future Investment Initiative” activities
held in Riyadh under the supervision of the Saudi Public Investment Fund,
44 international companies obtained licenses
allowing them to establish their regional headquarters in the region in the Saudi capital.
These companies included big names such as PepsiCo, Pricewaterhouse, KPMG, Deloitte, Unilever, Samsung, Siemens,
Dimension Data, Tim Hortons, Halliburton, Philips, Novartis, Johnson Controls, and Schlumberger.
And “500 Startups”, “Baker Hughes” - “Eli Lilly” -“SAP” - Medtronic, and others.
Almost half of the companies that obtained these licenses had already signed agreements
to transfer their regional headquarters to Riyadh months before, specifically in January 2021.
The other half were new companies negotiating with them for the first time
over the establishing their regional headquarters in Riyadh.
By the way, the Saudis do not want a large number of companies without considering their economic weight,
on the contrary, they only target companies whose annual revenues exceed one billion dollars.
Here an important question arises: What are the motives of those companies? Or,
more precisely, what drives them to establish their regional headquarters in Riyadh, rather than anywhere else?
Is their fear of being denied government contracts, starting in 2024, the only driver of their decisions?
This question takes us to the second aspect of the Saudi plan, which is the soft or easy side, i.e. the carrot.
Here we are talking about the incentives and facilities that the Saudi government provides to
international companies to persuade them to be present in the Saudi market.
These incentives include, for example:
Long-term tax exemption for large companies / zero taxes for 50 years / preferential treatment in government contracts,
and great facilities in terms of visa and sponsorship procedures for foreign employees and their families.
For example, among the things that bothered foreign employees who work in international companies operating in Saudi Arabia,
is that in order to go out to spend the weekend in Dubai or Bahrain, they must obtain an exit visa.
This issue is supposed to be addressed. There is also an exemption for a period of 10 years from the "Saudisation" policy,
which obliges companies to have a specified percentage of their employees Saudis.
Among the incentives is that the wives and husbands of foreign male and female employees
will be able to work in the country and obtain work permits. And their adult children, if they are over the legal age,
can live with their parents, and at the same time they will receive an education suitable for them in the city.
In April 2021, the Royal Commission for Riyadh City announced that it had signed a partnership with the British King's College
School to open the first international school in Riyadh, which they named King's College Riyadh.
In July of the same year, the Ministry of Investment and the Royal Commission for Riyadh City signed
a partnership with the Spanish group (SEK) to open its first international school in the capital as well.
This is only a part of the carrot, there is another part related to infrastructure..
Riyadh is close to completing a $27 billion transportation network in the city.
The most important part of this network is the Riyadh Metro, which consists of 6 lines.
In this context, it is also necessary to talk about the King Abdullah Financial District (KAFD),
as there is a plan to transform it into a special economic zone, exempt from entry visas and directly linked to Riyadh Airport.
This center, built in the north of Riyadh on an area of ​​approximately 1.6 million square meters
and which includes about 59 skyscrapers, will provide one million cubic meters of office space
and can be considered a cornerstone of Saudi Arabia's plan
to lure as many regional centers of international companies as possible in the region.
In addition, there are plans to establish a number of special economic zones in the city.
In late October, Saudi Arabia inaugurated the Special Logistics Zone on an area of ​​3 million square kilometers.
It is the first free zone in the Kingdom and is located within the territory of King Khalid International Airport in Riyadh.
According to the statements of the Saudi Minister of Transport and Logistics, "Saleh Al-Jasser",
the American company Apple is one of the first companies
that leased a place within this free zone to use it as a regional distribution center.
In total, Saudi Arabia announced that it intends to spend $220 billion
on developing Riyadh only in order to turn it into a global city by 2030.
Apart from this, Saudi Arabia in general has lots of qualifications that make it attractive for multinational companies.
More than 35 million people live there, making it the largest market in the Gulf region.
However, it has large areas of land, cheap energy, ports on the Red Sea,
and a huge petrochemical industry that can provide many production inputs for manufacturers.
All of the above are, in short, the most prominent tools that Saudi Arabia will use in its quest to be the largest host
for the regional centers of international companies in the region.
Saudi Arabia has been already into talks with about 7,000 companies worldwide
to lure them to open their regional centers in Riyadh.
It also aims, within 10 years, to lure the regional headquarters of about 480 international companies.
This is a pretty large number considering that Dubai, which is the most important financial city in the region,
does not have half as many regional centers.
According to a piece of information mentioned by the French News Agency in April 2021,
Dubai hosts about 140 regional headquarters of global companies.
This is the highest number in the region and most importantly,
Dubai has reached this number of regional headquarters over the course of 3 decades.
Therefore, some may see the Saudi plan as too optimistic, and others may see it as an exaggeration.
However, the Saudis see it as ambitious and commensurate with the size and significance of the Kingdom's economy
as the only country in the region to be part of the global G-20 group.
For us more important than ambition, optimism and pessimism is reality
- i.e. - apart from plans, declarations, optimism and pessimism, what is actually happening on the ground?
Last April, fDi Markets, issued by the Financial Times, said that by tracking the destination of 126 greenfield projects
that were revealed in Saudi Arabia during 2021,
55 of the projects are in Riyadh, and 14 of them were new regional centers.
Of course, some of you might see this number is pretty small, but on the contrary, this number is considerable.
It is worthy mentioning that from 2003 until the end of 2020, the main regional headquarters of foreign companies
that were established in Riyadh have not exceeded 11 centers. Now we are talking about 14 in just one year, which is 2021.
The remarkable thing is that the headquarters that have been or will be inaugurated in the future in Riyadh
are not all new headquarters set up for the first time in the region.
On the contrary, some of them were previously in Dubai and moved to Riyadh.
At the beginning of 2021, for example, the American company CSG decided to move its regional centers from Dubai to Riyadh.
The headquarters, as a matter of fact, were moved from the Emirates to Saudi Arabia,
and work began within two months only.
An incident like this shows that the rise and success of Riyadh will certainly and undoubtedly affect Dubai,
in short, there will be a strong and sought after competition between the two cities.
Official statements on the Saudi and Emirati sides downplay the competition too diplomatically.
What is said on the Saudi side is that Riyadh's ambition does not target either Dubai or Abu Dhabi,
and it is ultimately okay if Riyadh is going to be like Singapore and Hong Kong. On the other hand,
the Emiratis also see that competition is in the interest of the region. This is the diplomatic talk,
on the ground nevertheless, every city is fighting over its current or future leading position and role.
Dubai is very concerned in maintaining its current position as a significant financial and commercial center in the region,
so it has recently taken steps to ensure keeping that position. For example, in late June, Dubai announced a project called
"Dubai Global", which is a global network of 50 offices spread over five continents whose mission is marketing the city of Dubai
and creating opportunities for Dubai-based companies in 30 new markets around the world.
It is necessary to draw attention quickly to a matter of significance,
at the present time there are many things that distinguish Dubai from any other city in the region.
However, the two most significant features are: first, its ease for business inauguration.
Meaning, in 2020 the UAE in general ranked 16th globally and first in the Arab world in the ease of doing business index.
Saudi Arabia ranked 63rd, and that is an issue that Saudi Arabia is supposed to be addressing at the moment.
Second, the status of social openness in Dubai for international companies and their employees and foreign nationals in general,
which in their view is higher than its peer in Riyadh.
Meaning, the lifestyle and mores in Dubai, which is commensurate with being a global city,
is more comfortable for foreign officials and employees, most of whom are from countries whose lifestyle is open.
This is one of the reasons why the entertainment authority in Saudi Arabia has been trying for many months
to make Riyadh keep pace with Dubai on this point.
A crucial question popped up here: Why are we, as countries, supposed to compete to lure the largest possible number
of regional headquarters of giant international companies? What do we gain?
Yet, before answering such a question,
let's first explain what does it mean to have regional headquarters of an international company.
Attention please…
The first time that the concept of the Regional Head Quarter appeared was in the early sixties,
during that period, American companies were expanding in Europe
having activities and operations in European countries such as France, Germany and Britain.
With the amplification of business , American companies sought after an effective administration
in the old continent to manage its operations there efficiently.
Hence the idea of ​​a regional headquarters located in a country other than that of the parent company.
This headquarters is where part of the parent company's Chief Executive Officer is located,
and through it, the company's operations are managed at the regional level.
Among the first companies to do this were IBM when it opened a regional headquarters in Paris,
and Ford Motors when it opened one in London. That's simply the idea of a regional headquarters.
The Saudi government, within the framework of its regional headquarters program known as 'Programme HQ',
has set a specific definition for the regional headquarters, which is: “A unit of a multinational group
established under Saudi regulations for the purpose of supporting, managing
and providing strategic direction for its branches and subsidiaries operating in the Middle East and North Africa.”
Well, we know what a corporate headquarters means. But why would we want so many of them?
What is the point of that? I will tell you a quick anecdote of significance.
On September 7, 2017, the American e-commerce giant, "Amazon", announced its intention to open a new regional
headquarters in North America. So, for any city in North America that would like to have the new company headquarter on its land,
It has had to submit a file explaining why Amazon should choose it to set up the new headquarters.
Each city should explain exactly what advantages it will be offering…
Application closed on October 19, 2017, took about a month and a half.
Guess how many North American cities have submitted their bid to Amazon
and expressed interest in hosting the company's new regional headquarters?
Do you think it's 10 cities? 20 cities? 50 cities? Did any of you think of the number 100?
All of you probably got it wrong. On October 23 of the same year, Amazon declared that 238 cities in North America
had submitted bids to lure it to set up its new headquarters on its land.
Of course, it makes you wonder why all these cities did so? Will Amazon distribute money to the people and the local administration of the chosen city?
Actually, opposite of what you expected, the answer is yes. Amazon will distribute money.
This horrific turnout to participate in bidding for Amazon was a lust by these cities to the huge gains that will be achieved
if Amazon sets up its new regional headquarters known as [Amazon HQ2] on their land.
Amazon was planning to invest $5 billion in the new headquarters. It will directly employ 50,000 people.
Three times this number will be indirect labor, ie "150 thousand".
Let us now from Amazon .. Of course you know Switzerland? Famous for chocolate and watches?
About 25,500 multinational companies operate in that country.
They constitute only about 5% of the total companies in it, which is 580,000 companies.
Multinational corporations employ approximately 25-30% of the country's workforce,
which is directly equivalent to 1.3 million people. However, it is responsible for one-third of the gross domestic product,
and one-third of the tax revenues that enter the state treasury.
This is the type of major economic benefits that Riyadh and Dubai are competing for.
The Saudi government hopes that the regional headquarters program
will add to the Saudi economy by 2030 about 67 billion riyals, or 18 billion dollars, and create about 30,000 jobs.
Riyadh, to achieve this, will enter, as we said, in direct competition with Dubai.
It will not be an easy competition at all, given that Dubai has made great strides in all directions,
which has contributed to becoming one of the most important financial and business centers in the world.
The competition could also be a triple after the 2022 World Cup,
an event that will present Qatar, and Doha in particular, to the whole world as well.
Last March, the giant German car company "Volkswagen" established its regional headquarters for the Middle East
in the Qatari capital, Doha. Before Volkswagen, large companies such as Google and Microsoft
began running their regional activities from Qatar.
Last August, the Foreign Direct Investment Markets Bulletin / fDi Markets /
said that Qatar attracted 71% of all investments in the Middle East during the second quarter of 2022.
This contributed to the creation of 6,680 job opportunities in 11 projects, With investments amounting to 19.2 billion US dollars.
In the end, I would like to say that the Middle East and North Africa region can accommodate four, five and six
financial centers at the same time, given that it has huge untapped potential.
In the 1970s, Hong Kong emerged as the first and largest financial center in the Asia Pacific region.
Years later, Singapore and Shanghai competed with it for its position as the financial center of the region.
Today, after decades of competition, the three cities not only became financial centers, but also rank among the top 10
all over the world. Singapore is the third, Hong Kong fourth, and Shanghai sixth.
We hope to see Riyadh, Cairo, Doha, Abu Dhabi, Casablanca and other major Arab capitals
among the most important financial centers in the world, next to Dubai,
which leads the scene as a financial center on the regional level, and in an advanced position on the global level.
All the best to the Saudi siblings in their ambitious plans, wishing the same for the rest of the Arab cities.
I am done here, and in the end I have a question for you guys:
if you would choose an Arab city to live or settle in for a potential prosperous future, which city would you choose?
I will follow all your answers in the comments, and I hope if you like the episode, like the video,
share it with your friends and loved ones, and tell them about us, they may take advantage of it
- and above all - subscribe to the channel as we said, Good Bye...